the eu is mourning the loss of european
parliament president david de sassoli
just moments ago his colleagues gathered
on the steps of the parliament to hold a
minute of silence in his memory
mr sasuori died at the age of 65. the
italian center-left politician had been
in the hospital since december 26
struggling for months with poor health
after suffering pneumonia the former
journalist became president
in 2019 a vote to elect his replacement
had already been planned for later this
month since mr sasoli had already
decided not to run for reelection
like to go now to brussels standing
right outside the european parliament is
dw's jack perrick jack mr cesoli's death
has come as a shock frankly to many what
are some of the reactions that you've
seen and heard where you are
well we saw later later a number of meps
outside the european parliament during
that moment silence here in tears this
was a very well liked man here in
brussels around the european parliament
and indeed in all of the european
union's institutions
we had a report from his team from his
office uh on monday to say that he had
actually been in hospital in italy and
vanilla
since
the 26th of december and then we woke up
this morning to the news that in fact he
had passed away now the european
commission president ursula vandalia she
gave a short video statement earlier in
which she said he was a man of deep
faith and strong convictions and he
constantly defended the values of the
european union
now he's obviously one of those
quintessential europeans and he's being
remembered as a passionate european what
more can you tell us about david sasoli
who was david sasoli
well he was born in florence in italy in
1957 and spent much of the 80s and the
90s working as a journalist in italy and
ended up becoming a prominent anger
anchor on a major italian news network
one of the stories that he was famous
for covering was the fall of the berlin
wall and the reunification of germany
which is obviously significant then
entering european politics in 2009 that
moment is vital for the idea of european
unity now he was re-elected uh here at
the european parliament a few times and
after the 2019 elections it was decided
that he would take the first half of the
mandate as the european parliament
president his mandate was only going to
end next week
um exactly is 10 years european uh
parliament's president about to end next
week as you have been reporting who is
likely to be a successor
well we know that roberta metzeler who's
an epp member of the european
parliament a different party the
centre-right party rather than the
center left party is most likely to take
the presidency as agreed by the
political group she was here outside the
european parliament to mark the moment
with her fellow colleagues and the staff
of the european parliament and she
tweeted earlier on to say that she's
heartbroken that europe has lost a
leader and that she has lost a friend
there's a lot of sadness in and around
brussels
over the death of david sassoli the
president of the european parliament who
died at the age of 65.
brussels correspondent jack
talking to us from right outside the
european parliament in brussels thank
you